oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Oh
do it again with your finger welcome
back guys we took off week for
Thanksgiving but we are back we did
wanna see you so lovely to see you
looks like you're comfortable are you
wearing me undies oh if you're not it's
okay I'm not mad I really am not mad
darling mad you okay I'm a little mad
but you can be right now and you get 20%
of your first pair Sophos under in the
world three times softer than cotton
amazing designs like ridiculously
comfortable you won't wear another type
of underwear once you try me and he's
gonna meet undies calm /gen there's only
that's Emmie undies dot-com / Jenna
Jillian 20% off you will not be sorry
what's this tiny thing in my pocket it's
so tiny oh it's a track or pixel Julian
this is just tracking pixel guys this
episode is also brought to you by a
tracker this is a tiny device like you
can't even see it from here can you even
see it
poof it's gone this is a tiny device
that GPS tracks your items so you don't
lose them your wallet your phone your
belongings your backpack whatever it is
your dog you put this thing on your
items and then it connects with your
phone on the tracker app and you find it
you never lose anything okay it's really
really helpful and it's so incredibly
tiny battery lasts forever not literally
but you know what I mean go to the
tracker that's th e TR ACK our comm /
Jenna Julian for 20% off because if
you're gonna get an awesome gift this
season you don't want to lose it
alright oh [ __ ] we fight I'm literally
wearing me undies underwear and the
bralette I'm not wearing a bra that the
bralla is like the you know ladies out
this if you feel me like sometimes when
you're at like around your house or like
lounging or something and you would like
just not wear a bra but maybe you want
to wear a sweatshirt or something and
you don't want to shave so you want like
a
low support bra just like a comfy lounge
bra like those of the portlets it was
like not quite full bra but not quite
yeah like I'm I'm not gonna let them go
do a bunch of jumping jacks but it's
like a nice chill lounge bra without
like an underwire or I don't know Jax
you potentially could even just not work
no ya know if someone's a jumping jacks
fan you can still buy me andis okay
that's what I'm getting at you can do
whatever you want
and you brought lit but like it for me
it's like the perfect
I'm chillin bra it's good way to
describe it you know mm-hmm
we chillin it's gelid well we had a
Thanksgiving up in the mountains it was
it was pretty nice to get up there but
where we like got back home and like
kind of had just like chills giving yeah
we're just giving weekend yeah we had
some leftovers
we made our fried chicken that we made
last year for Thanksgiving so obviously
we're vegan and Julian can't any gluten
so people are like what do you guys need
for Thanksgiving we literally take
beyond meat the chicken strips Julian
makes a flour batter for them and like
we deep-fry them and we put like extra
rosemary and thyme and sage in there and
it tastes a lot like Thanksgiving and
then we made mashed potatoes
I made stuffing and cranberry sauce and
honestly what the [ __ ] else you need
oven just a couch to digest not just the
couch digest on the couch Oh 11 of you
guys who found my Pinterest somehow know
what that recipe is but found your
pincers something like that I don't know
how do I have your Pinterest I follow
you on Pinterest as I find all the know
you do yeah but cuz Julian does this
thing or we're gonna cook something and
he's like look up the recipe and like
just open my Pinterest on your phone
it's a great app but I don't know why
anyone would follow me on it
do you though it is always a little
funny when someone's like so-and-so is
now following your Pinterest and you're
like why why him why am I never post her
and if I do it's like literally just so
I remember where the recipe is it's all
good though so we give him credit to
this person for the tweet yeah Zandar
that was the original tweet and then a
lot of people tweeted it at us it was
like immediately and overwhelmingly this
is what people wanted us to do when the
podcast I think it's a really funny idea
basically what it is is its headline
rule and read the tweet so the tweet
says that was tweeted at us by Zander
says every single headline this year
looks like someone pulled names and
scenarios out of a hat that wasn't that
wasn't the tweet at you that was just a
tweet and that they quoted a New York
Daily News article that says Tommy
Hilfiger thinks model Gigi Hadid could
be the key to peace in the Middle East
so the idea is literally we're gonna do
that we're gonna pull like headlines out
of a hat so we separated them into three
categories okay we have the who we have
the who category who it's about we have
the what category what the subject is he
has a good action and then and like a
follow-up yeah cuz I didn't I didn't
want it to just like again whenever we
do these like cup games it might not
work but I'm hoping it does because it
we wrote separately yeah we so a lot of
them I don't know and Julian doesn't
know I'm excited I'm hoping that they
all work together but I didn't want it
to be like you know we pull out Donald
Trump and then it's like buys a llama
farm I feel like that's kind of yeah we
had to have a third this adds this adds
a whole nother dimension to it
yeah cuz this can change both the WHO
and the what yeah probably won't work
together it's hopefully more than not
they will so you know no how do you want
so how do we do it the normal way where
I pull all three make my sentence you
pull all three and we decide who's wins
right then in there yeah the winners
pile goes in Ohio me decide later on
what the yes okay is that good
yeah I feel like we we like might have
too many I know you how many did you do
I don't even know because I want to get
yours are all on the top I wanna get to
some of my mine are good yeah
I'm just trying to make some more oh no
don't do that because then they're
different beasts the paper don't shake
them you got to just dig your hand in
there and fish around all right you go
first all right
you pick your who your what your and
I'll pick them as well I'll just read
them a second
minor on notebook paper yeah I'm taking
off got one of yours yeah you got a fish
for the other ones too okay oh boy this
is fun as hell I [ __ ] love this [ __ ]
yeah that's funny okay you go first
sorry I got ooh Chingy y'all remember
the best rapper in the world Chingy
okay Chingy steals own mom's identity so
he can tell himself to go through her
room that doesn't make any sense
Julianne what does that mean what do you
not get it
oh he steals his own his own mom's
identity so he can tell himself two
coats spell himself to go to his own
freaking ground himself and did so well
hip thrusting 400 kilograms in the bath
okay it's okay
nothing change the best part of that one
jiggy is the best far as that one Kym
Johnson just impromptu you proposed to
Elon Musk at TEDx at a TEDx talk but
won't confirm their own story I think
yours woods yeah this one's better this
one's a little better yeah you just
proposed to Elon Musk at a TEDx talk
like how did how did he even get to that
TEDx talk no no but he was there but he
won't confirm it is that a plausible
headline though you think yeah yeah yeah
a few diffuse no it is it was really
into the United States what if the TEDx
talk was enough free mm-hmm okay gotcha
gotcha [ __ ]
gotcha [ __ ] Oh drama [ __ ] keep trying
the [ __ ] Oh drama [ __ ] prob a [ __ ]
how Europe I do feel like like the 20:17
comments much like these 2017 headlines
is like this whole year has just been a
[ __ ] show yeah for real all right I got
Ray Drummond with you you spelled that
with an H in there does she still have
an H I think she just felt it REE I
don't know all right REE Drummond got
arrested on a New York subway for quote
dropping it to the floor way too hard
and then open hand slapped an entire
bowl of macaroni salad off a nearby
table okay
a and C go together right there slap the
macaroni salad yeah yeah yeah okay shut
off the fan sure whatever you want
intercept I'm interested to see if you
can beat that because this is the sauce
right here this is the sauce Adam driver
mustard off at a mustered up enough cash
from investors to bring back vine oh
hell yeah and then toss the ball of raw
dough into the air and yell it's a me
amariah those are all mine all the red
ones are mine you did both the people
are yours which one wins Missy you read
I think there's some wins what yours
your third one is a trump card must toss
the dead ball down the aaron yelled it's
a me a Mario it's pretty good I'm okay
if that wins all right this one was read
the headline altogether yacht and driver
yep mustered up enough cash from
investors to bring back mine and then
toss the ball of raw dough into the air
and yo it's a Mia Mario hell yeah it
makes sense because he's like
celebrating the the vines gonna come
here Oh
drop me [ __ ] right I can't stop putting
umm most funds when I saw him flying
thread the other day and it just oh man
it brought me back I was on buying more
than anyone either of us know
collectively even our friends that were
like Brian creators well we don't know
yeah ha no no yes I okay more fun I had
an actual [ __ ] problem yours are so
big why are your papers some larger than
my hand okay
oh you go first okay I didn't put that
in there it's just a blank piece of
paper there's no one on it there's also
a blank one wait no that's Oprah all
right go for it ok Oprah just announced
that they were running for president via
musically 2020
and then started eating during yoga oh
my god your class and use here like it
was turn around your and it's Oprah and
she's just eating a cheeseburger oh well
are you eating in yoga it's just like
I'm running for president check out my
musically [ __ ]
that's great Oprah but why are you
eating in the yoga studio I feel like
that's a plausible headline yeah it
could happen and then started eating
during yoga yeah it could yeah alright I
got Justin Timberlake saw Taylor Swift
gremlin walking out of a Pinkberry
bathroom gremlin walking it's an
activity gremlin walk like when you walk
forgiven on your hands with your flat
towards the ground
forgive me all right Justin Timberlake's
saw Taylor Swift gremlin walking out of
a Pinkberry bathroom and then tweeted
later the earth is flat idiots I don't
know I think you got a bunch with the
second one i butchered it what no this
one saw Taylor Swift gremlin walking out
of a Pinkberry bathroom yeah but no real
but and you know when you're like no I
get what grim oh my god oh we're getting
a demonstration like that no I get it I
think yours with Oprah eating yours is
like a real thing so far you've won
everything well we've won cuz these are
half your cards anyway it's [ __ ] HQ
starting out like why oh [ __ ] I've
gotten to question 11 and then I got
question 11 wrong and then I just feel
terrible and want to die we hike you
want to get Scott Rogowski on a podcast
yeah if you guys are into that I don't
know we'll try we'll try try here we go
oh we both did Michael Kors no way
alright go ahead
alright Michael Kors wishes yesterday
didn't happen and then pooped outside of
Wendy's for no apparent reason
whatsoever
I feel like that's such a thing that
could happen wishes yesterday didn't
happen and then pooped outside of
Wendy's for no apparent like he was just
walking around one day was being a
little Kunti and was like yeah what I
was yesterday never happened and then
destruction possible okay Alex Jones
isn't sure if the Super Bowl is still a
thing and then ripped open his shirt to
reveal the most exquisite jewel the bra
no but I really like yours
any-anything following Alex Jones name
is possible hmm anything that would have
had Alex Jones isn't sure the Super Bowl
is still experiencing that like maybe
the Super Bowl still doesn't happen it
is it's fake it's not a real thing but I
was I was sort of writing like someone
who's just super out of the loop and
pop-culture and there's like no is this
telothane even though it's like a
massive sporting event every year him
it's a conspiracy theory yeah like that
like has there ever been this Super Bowl
I think that's the one we pick okay I
mean this is my winter pass is the Super
Bowl still even a thing and then you
strips up at his shirt I'm here for that
I would watch that on YouTube the
highlights of it mm-hmm i watch it live
on youtube because he would be streaming
for sure for sure for sure they are sure
dude alright you first guys go in HQ for
us all right this isn't very specific it
just says Victoria's Secret model they
meant as a oh okay alright a Victoria's
Secret model suggested we all quote just
go back to the [ __ ] barter system
while wearing extreme white face and
their butt scooting across the US for
charity interesting white face yeah yeah
what this [ __ ] suggested we all
quote just go back to the [ __ ] barter
system while wearing extreme white face
my god
earn it what you got Chrissy Teigen
yells the national anthem at her son and
then showed up at a child's birthday
party but ass naked okay that's too real
that has to mean that's a plausible
scenario this is a headline I feel like
are you ready yeah that's someone having
just like a mental breakdown but just
really quick can you like picture
someone yelling the National like a
discipline like a disciplinary measure
like you're just getting yelled at
within national anthem I feel like
that's a thing that could happen Tom
wins and that's no disrespect to Chrissy
Teigen I feel like it could happen to
anyone
I followed her on Twitter recently she's
funny yes she's always been funny well I
know I'm late to the party but I'm still
just making an observation that she's
funny mmm there's shoot funny going out
you know who won't pay my buck doubt why
is he talking that child I'll go first
okay the rock sends threatening sends a
threatening text to a guy who clapped
when their plane landed and then audibly
farted into a Dasani I love that you
take Dasani because that's like the
worst water ever okay I don't know if I
can beat that whatever I have I don't
know if I can beat that how do you get
that guy's number
I don't know to threaten him via attack
maybe he air dropped in his contest
possibly all right mine is a small-town
garbage man with nothing to lose
says Nicholas Cage is the one true God
and is found duct-taped to a life-size
statue of themself no you win that one's
incredible read it again The Rock sends
a threatening text to a guy who clapped
when his plane landed and then audibly
farted into a your chump Krauts are
killing it right now just like the rock
is sitting first class on
in giant huge men takes an empty Dasani
bottle that he just crushed and just
[ __ ] rips acid rips into it looks
around no one's gonna say [ __ ] because
it's the rock no one's gonna say [ __ ]
your first alright
I have Abraham Lincoln okay back from
the dead
held a rally for vegetable rights
claiming they know when they being eaten
is [ __ ] up we air now and then just
tried to drive a jetski to Cuba from
Miami just to get away from you [ __ ]
that's plausible things everyone
nowadays a [ __ ] boy he's dead but he
probably does though
how can the via headline if he's dead
I'm so itchy Kylie Jenner says the
iPhone 10 is her favorite new item to
put up her ass and also sat on her
Nintendo switch and his pissed at the
iPhone 10 matched perfectly with the
Nintendo sir like that was this
anonymous thing I love she puts the
iPhone 10 up her ass but the Nintendo
switch is like too much she's pissed she
sat on it it's probably broken now
alright no I love the get away from you
[ __ ] you win forever if mines not
plausible Abraham Lincoln's dead alright
fine
he was really good thanks I got a Jena
card another Jena car think I got this
one wonder how HQ wet well Jenna cards
oh my god I'm ready for this one
should I start yeah Mark Zuckerberg went
on a retreat to become an actual merman
and then waived a pair of citizen deer
and says it's Christmas time fit yours
like each card of yours
tell us the story yeah I love it I like
that one hello
all right I got Michael Kors again but
Julian's Michael Kors says champagne has
no bubbles cuts of dice
all right and then probably left the
country in a hot-air balloon they
crashed shortly after because who the
[ __ ] knows how to fly a hot-air balloon
but everyone was okay Michael of course
champagne has no bubbles yes and a
hot-air balloon flies over the country
in crashes I just love the idea that
someone's like in a state of anger and
they leave it takes like ten minutes to
blow it up with the hot air and then a
while laughter just so let's drop the
grounds like 20 yards away an hour later
no then he finally cuts the rope with a
giant knife so you can get going
so this was I think yours winds
Zuckerberg gotten Ammerman and then said
it's Christmas time [ __ ] it's Christmas
time one two Trey do you first girl I
got Elijah and Christine are pretty like
sure they got pregnant for their
birthday oh my god and won't admit their
driver's license photo is actually him
what I don't know
yeah and I guess that one doesn't really
translate yeah I don't get that one
pulling on another end what I don't know
what that means right fine what does
that mean it won't advance it sounded
better in my head
all right Elijah and Christine are like
pretty sure they got pregnant on their
birthday but wouldn't interrupt their
arithmetic class to comment any further
arithmetic what again arithmetic I just
thought it would be funny if someone was
in arithmetic class I am NOT a funny man
Donald Trump shows off his new Beachbody
it's not his but it's a great body while
spitting into the air in cash
back in the mouth all right I tried to
make my work it didn't work
yours came out phenomenal all right
amazing
read it again when Donald Trump shows
off a new Beachbody it's not his but
it's a great body while spinning up into
the air and catching it back in the
mouth
thank you thank you that I feel like
that's a real thing though that could
happen I mean I think of my body it's a
great body now my body but it's a great
body this is my body and then he's just
on the beach spitting up in the air and
catching his mouth
yeah that's a honey thing with Donald
Trump in front of it is completely
believable at this point it's show
380 Fox 380 [ __ ] all right what you got
boy right kendall Jenner asks on
November 29th what time is the World
Series start it's funny if you know what
sports okay you know and they're and
they're gonna turn their life around but
only once they've had their morning
coffee in whatever that was bad I have
shane dawson petitioned to make the
spongebob theme song the new national
anthem and wore a salad as a hat and
screamed [ __ ] all y'all all y'all can
suck a scallop illa dick to a small
group of people minding their own
business these are both kind of kind of
weak that ones get them [ __ ] oh yo all
y'all can suck Akala pill okay that was
a vine reference nobody wins that's not
going in the wind all right no one wins
not bad that was not right
not great some of these like I think the
problem is I wrote them in like a column
and they only worked with what was next
to them which is stupid because they're
supposed to be right and I know you've
got to write them all in the same like
tents - I mean that's horror
I know it's ID okay what Ellen says
singing underwater is completely safe
and proves it by pooping on the floor in
the first-class airport lounge oh my god
you had a pooping somewhere hunt floor -
yeah we sick
like that one though it's really good I
was like guys you can sing underwater
it's safe amazing all right
Hillary Clinton dug an actual hole to
China when asked how she did it she said
Shh don't worry about it
and also can't find his [ __ ] car keys
his or her guys I dug a hole at China
Oh miss Clinton how did you do that Shh
don't worry about it does anyone see my
[ __ ] keys sounds good
that one wins no one wins that's pretty
sure with loser keys though she had a
tracker on them oh that Segway though
boy tiny device that you can attach to
your items okay and by the way I just
like for the record to show that you set
me up with that I did not plan that you
set me up with I did not plan that I
didn't know I was setting you up you set
me up with that guy's tracker pixel is
their new tiny tiny little thing here it
is right here right your phone your keys
your wallet things in my backpack
backpack we we took it to Portugal we
everywhere we go we put these on our
things you put it on whenever you lose
your wallet whatever it is okay I put
mine on my in my drawing bag in my
camera bag cuz can't risk losing those
things I actually used the tracker app
on our last last minute trip a month ago
when we were at the airport our look is
just taking forever to come around so
wait a minute this is weird so I'm
logging on the app and it showed me that
it's LAX I was like huh I can rest easy
hi a peace of mind now and that's what
tracker gives you is peace of mind
honestly any time you might be worried
that you might lose an item just throw a
tracker pixel on it it has GPS tracker
in it that communicates with your phone
okay so you lose an item you log on your
phone it gives you a map and it shows
you where it is it just locates your
item it's always tracked via the tracker
it also works backwards where if you
lose your phone you have the tracker you
can make your phone create a noise so
you can find it so if your phones across
the room you don't know where it is you
have your tracker help where's my phone
you press it and your phone will buzz
it's a really really cool item and it
also has a light on it so you can find
things in the dark and you can locate
things even if they're miles and miles
away because tracker is part of the
biggest crowd locate network in the
world
so it will show you its last location on
that map I'm telling you this is a small
investment that's gonna serve you tons
and tons of peace of mind very highly
recommended and if you go to the tracker
comm that's th e TR AC car CK our
apologies comm / underling you get 20%
off and it's really not that expensive
to start with okay so it's a good deal
check them out and while you're on the
internet buying things go to me Indies
calm and get yourself some new underwear
they have new designs every month micro
model fabric three times softer than
cotton okay they have bra let's now
they're introducing a whole new line of
things I may or may not have seen a
onesie being teased on their Instagram
yeah imagine of Mandy's onesie oh my god
it's that they have pants are already so
soft yeah and then they also have new
socks which they released this year but
they're the bread and butter is their
undies and if you've never worn me at
least you need to track because it is so
incredibly comfortable you're not going
to understand how you wore any other
pair of underwear before that right now
you got to meet undies comm / Jun and
Julian you get 20% of your first order
free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee which means you
guys are not going to return these
undies I promise you okay the awesome
team they sponsor our Twitter stream
they sponsor the podcast for a long time
you love them so much they're literally
one of our twitch emotes we made which
amount just for me yeah we'll just be
playing pub G and people are typing in
me and ease me and you know it's really
really awesome product highly recommend
now for us eating with the important
business we have well you're important
to me wonder what happened in HQ I don't
know oh the prize was eight thousand
dollars tonight we done blew it sham one
I don't see one like six dollars alright
you ready
I have Suzanne wash Nicki which I see
that you spelled with an N just like how
I thought but apparently there's no end
in her name if you go back and like
listen to those podcasts while we're
talking about it I'm saying Susan was
Nikki there's never been oh I just
sounded I just sounded
but isn't that crazy it's like the
[ __ ] Mandela effect it's making me
feel crazy okay Susan Wojcicki thinks
not only that the world is flat but also
that you're a [ __ ] but their new fall
line is still on schedule yo not only
Zara flat but you're a [ __ ] Q
collectively Gordon Ramsay pulls out but
it's pretty sure it's fine and then
holds a solid plank for 64 minutes
Julian what the [ __ ] what that
absolutely wins it absolutely wins sorry
again yes Gordon Ramsay pulls out but
it's pretty sure it's fine and then
holds a solid plank for 64 minutes
straight like on what planet would that
be an article what does the article
include him pulling out being 90 percent
sure it's cool everything's fine and
then he holds a plank oh my god by the
way that guy is an incredible shape for
his age so he can hold that 64 minute
plank probably I'm sure he could that's
a long plank but after pulling out who
knows what he's capable of oh he's sick
you please it that way I just want to
hear a surgeon wasn't if you told me I'm
a [ __ ] oh we're almost out of the
action cards all right I got Sean Evans
from hot ones wishes that Elsa from
frozen has the secret to good skin
didn't work the guy that puppeteer is
Kermit the Frog claims he is the print
he is pregnant with the next winner of
American Ninja Warrior and has already
invested in six Arby's locations yes yes
that's totally possible imagine claiming
you're pregnant with the winner of like
a sporting event in the one you pick is
American Ninja Warrior and then you're
like mmm
finish getting these obvious y'all
collecting RVs kind of catching them all
RVs you gotta catch yeah I know goddamn
goddamn goddamn boy damn boy I like this
next one it's got my favorite singer
okay what is it
cher has never actually existed and says
no take C's backsies if that was an
article I would click on it I would read
the [ __ ] out of them what is that she
probably has already claimed that she's
never existed and I'm sure has in person
in conversation said no takes these back
what is that article about she has a
come-to-jesus moment where she realizes
she doesn't exist and never has and is
so confident it says note a C's face
don't take some taxis fair enough
mine is Tiffany Pollard aka New York was
spotted back flipping into a public pool
wallet freight friendsgiving
in the sewer by LAX who's Tiffany
Pollard ah do not who Julian who is
Julian who is you know who that is
is it is it from New York Julian is it
the show that reality show Flavor of
Love I Love New York
yeah that one that's New York but she
was on Flavor of Love forgive me for not
knowing New York by her wrong name which
is in New York her name is New York
that's you know all of them my name is
New York the one when you sent the gift
of me with a knife that's New York
that's New York
yeah she's terrified then why did you
say who's New York I said who's Tiffany
Pollard oh because that's like saying
who's Bruce Wayne Oh Batman you should
you just hit that man did you just
compare New York to Batman a little bit
uh years winds okay far all right
that I think that's honestly next to the
Alex Jones thing this is so believable
mmm sure she's a loose cannon she claims
that she never existed
and no Dacey's backsies probably do well
use the middle one for both of these
how's that okay go give me the person
over here no will each do our own
sharing the middle one oh yeah I mean
all right I got Ethan and Neela all the
sudden can only sing in Dothraki and
used to be an alien but also still could
be Wendy Williams all of a sudden can
only sing in Dothraki
and then she prone called quor'toth and
then she prone crawl the backwards into
a local Chili's what the [ __ ] honestly
Wendy Williams I don't know what she's
gonna do next I could see her prone
crawling backwards into a Chili's let's
pick it up you can't there no more what
about this one and is in a perpetual
state of forgetting their phone charger
Pig yeah week that's it
well I want to read the rest of the
people that we didn't get to all of a
sudden can only sing in Dothraki
Sam Smith Paris Hilton Matt Damon
Beyonce and Nick Lachey damn it Nick
Lachey quintic I love Nick Lachey all
right are we doing a winner's around
here y'all so winners are all right are
those all your winners yeah damn it okay
start at the top Donald Trump shows off
beat new Beachbody it's not his but it's
a great body while spitting up into the
air and catching it back in the mouth
that's incredible I only have three
winners
I think this Kylie Jenner one can go the
iPhone X yeah okay
Kim jong-un just impromptu proposed Elon
Musk but won't confirm their own story
yeah
know what else you got we got to come up
with the most plausible 2017 headline
the puppeteer that claims they're
pregnant with American Ninja Warrior now
whoa
you're just gonna lemonade them without
asking me sure do you like that one
it's okay you can eliminate it sighs all
right all right Alex Jones isn't sure if
the Super Bowl is still a thing and then
ripped open his shirt to reveal the most
exquisite jeweled bra
I'm so good all right it's still going
this is the still going round all right
still going around the rock yeah sounds
really good that one's incredible the
Chrissy Teigan yells the national anthem
at her son and then shows up but ass
naked to a child's birthday it's
plausible it's good but it doesn't
compete with these I don't think okay
then get rid of it
bye Chrissy what else Gordon Ramsay
pulling out and then holding a plank for
an hour
it's so [ __ ] weird I'll leave that
one up to you
I think we can get rid of mine we are we
ending up with one yeah let's be the
ultimate winner I think we can get rid
of this Hillary Clinton won Doug an
actual hole to China when asked how she
did it she said don't worry about it and
also can't find her [ __ ] car keys
yeah that one just served as a purpose
to segue into the sponsors am i right oh
my god Oprah that was good just
announced they're running for president
via musically and then start eating yeah
it's so really good eating during yeah
all right I want to see these like on
actual headlines like Photoshop right so
fine Michael Kors says champagne has no
bubbles and then promptly left the
country at a hot air balloon
shortly after okay stop okay Adam driver
must have enough cash to bring back mine
then toss the ball go into the air get
rid of it good but we compared comparing
Li I'd say my top ones are Oprah cher
The Rock The Rock Alex Jones and
I don't know the rocking options are and
then shares pretty good yeah I mean
these are all good I feel like the rock
is my top but the Donald Trump was great
I feel like the rock woman should just
win the rock one should just read it
again the rock sends threatening text to
a guy who clapped on his plane landed
and then audibly farted into a Dasani
bottle so good it's so good if that was
an article I would click like theirs in
the in the article there's a picture of
a plane a Dasani bottle and the rock and
you're just like I guess that happened
oh my god what if we took the MVPs here
and made like Frankenstein's the best
one okay go for it so big share are you
gonna make a Frank in one Frank and I
said oh sorry go ahead
nice nice what else are you gonna pick
uh-huh okay yup are you doing sure says
champagne has no bubbles while spitting
up into the air and catching it back in
the mouth
it's gross that's gross that's not Frank
anyone good for share Cheers share did
alright my franken one is Michael course
just announced he's running for
president via musically and then audibly
farted into a dishonor on let me do
something for you there what Alex juice
announced he's running for president via
musically and then audibly farted into
it is I could see him firing an air
design about yeah yeah that's pretty
good
mmm-hmm all right I really like that
card just anybody audibly farting into
it Dasani bottle I guess wins the skin I
like this one what Oprah says no Tacy's
matches
and then olive leaf arson to identify
everything everything ends of that
everything ends with that this is fun
yeah that was fun I feel like these
roulette games are fun but they always
take like a sort of trial right because
we've done a couple episodes of each one
mm-hmm so I feel like we kind of know a
little better
moving into like if we were to do a
sequel on this one headline roulette to
or something yeah also if there's like
an angle we missed like let us know you
know yeah but this is fun it's still fun
and funny and it's one of my favorite
things to do I was just like sitting
down yeah and making things up it's
making funny things about pulling things
out of it but also like I'm at my
computer just like chuckling to myself
yes I think I'm funny but you know half
of the [ __ ] I write it's like so dumb
it's fun it's fun
doesn't matter it's fun it's fine oh wow
my heart thanks anyway yeah whoa oh oh
[ __ ] who are you fighting you're going
on your last LM t of the year tomorrow
are you excited I am leaving you really
I mean I'm excited I am excited I can't
believe the years like over and we've
we've done all the ones we've done it's
kind of crazy to think about but I'm
excited yeah I'm curious this is the way
we're gonna go I'm gonna map I don't
know if you threw a dart in the same
exact location would you go back no I
would send Colin and I would just stay
home no well this podcast will be we're
gonna probably already have finished the
d'Arthur about the time this goes up but
yeah we're leaving tomorrow we don't
know where which is always interesting
because I packed like I have to pack
like first spectrum of temperatures yeah
exactly yeah in conditions - yeah but um
you know missing yeah I'm gonna miss you
oh you sweet anyway we'll be back next
week with another podcast I hope you
guys all had a wonderful Thanksgiving
and I hope you're powering through the
Thanksgiving break yes and the holiday
break because I know you want to get
there a good time we all wanted to be
Christmas already just go half a season
or whatever
holidays let's go ahead yeah we love you
guys
have a great week and we'll see you next
time
[Music]